this is traveling the country visiting
bookstores libraries festivals and
authors here are some of the people on
places we visited kondu Braun author of
the shadow of the Silk Road
what is the Silk Road the Silk Road
almost no longer exists but it was the
greatest international trade route of
its day
doing about 6,000 miles across the heart
of Asia how did you decide to write
about the Silk Road
I had always I've spent 40 years being
fascinated by Asia and the Silk Road
linked all those countries that had
missed interested me in that time in
other words Central Asia which was the
old part of the old Soviet Union the
Islamic Soviet Union western China
Afghanistan Iran all these countries the
one common denominator I could find was
that the Silk Road ran through them what
how did you research for this book I
researched mainly through languages I
have always wrestled all my life with
speaking Mandarin and Chinese Mandarin
Chinese and Russian and it was the this
was my main research obviously I read
the obvious books about the Silk the
lands through which it passed back in
the UK but my main desire was to be able
to talk to people along the way and so I
had to brush up my very bad Russian and
Mandarin so you actually traveled the
entire Silk Road yourself I travelled
7,000 miles from Xian which was the
ancient capital of a unified China where
the Terracotta Warriors are 2,000 years
ago and then westward across northwest
China into who's Becky Stan Kyrgyzstan
down over the Oxford server into
Afghanistan which was Harry and then
across Iran to the Mediterranean where
the Silk Road ended in most times its
Antioch which is now a little Turkish
town how did the turn out of the name
the Silk Road come about okay she did
sort of misnomer it was never known by
that in in the in its heyday it was a
term coined by a German geographer in
the nineteenth century
where does the Silk come from with the
silk is a Chinese manufacturer
and they kept it secret for century as
nobody knew how it was made in fact the
Romans assumed that it was combed off
the leaves of trees and forests by a
people called the Sirius where they
hardly knew who they imagined were a
peaceful nation living in some sort of
magical ocean far off to the east the
Chinese have a similar notion that the
Romans were just people ruled by
philosopher kings and so silk was
unknown and these Goods did never came
by one merchant carrying them all the
way they went from hand to hand
so they accuse of accumulated value as
well as a kind of magic the further they
went from their origins by the time silk
reached them or Constantinople or
somewhere in the West it was filled with
myth and and stories how far back to the
origins of this route how far back are
they traced it's unknown they began
officially in the second century BC but
in fact it was going long before that
because you find Chinese silk curiously
turns up in the hair of a 10th century
BC Egyptian mummy it lies in the graves
of an aged Germany and so on say it long
precedes any real comic lling of the
Silk Road what does the history of the
Silk Road have to say about today's you
know the region today well I think the
effect its had has been to make the
borders all rather muddled and often not
having any relevance to the ethnic
realities so you cross border after
border and because this was a sort of
fluid world of merchants and tribes and
people nomads something of that has
remained for instance 4000 miles within
China you meter people are not Chinese
at all a week of people whose land it is
the borders of Central Asia or most of
other artificial created by Stalin in
the 1920s Afghanistan's and ethnic mez
and so it goes on even the last border I
crossed which is that between Iran and
Turkey there were nearly aliens
Turks that's all Kurds what would you
want a reader to take away from this
book well travel books a strange in a
way I think they don't give a message
specifically then what kind of
evangelical in that way or even like an
academic work saying you know this is
how it is what you hope of you will do
is to travel with you with your sense of
sort of exploration in country after
country and I hope what they would take
away it would be obvious enjoyment and
the sense of of energy the
extraordinaire nests of this route and
the relevance obviously of those
countries that it's left behind in
particular now Afghanistan Iran Central
Asia these countries would have suddenly
become important to us how long did the
journey take you it only took me eight
months people are often surprised by
this because it seemed a long and I was
it was held up at times by fighting in
Afghanistan fighting between warlords I
mean and by the SAS fathers in China I
was quality in force on the edge of the
Chinese desert so it took me a little
over eight months in all do you know how
long it would have taken someone
centuries ago to make the journey it
would of course nobody did the entire
journey or almost never and I guess if
you had wanted to do it in a good camel
train it would taken you a year and a
half something like that but the times
always varied and the goods as I say
were constantly exchanging hands and
sort of relay race so nobody ever did it
from them from the China Sea to the
Mediterranean did to them and what is
your background well I I don't have an
academic background I was fascinated by
writing as a child my father was an Army
officer and so I was used to travel even
as a child he was a military attache in
Ottawa worked in the States
and as a child as a post war child in
England coming to the states and to
Canada was amazing I've never even seen
a neon light before and suddenly I was
in New York in time of squares and ATOL
completely dazzled and I think something
of that fascinate
with the wonders of abroad and a
movement of travel stayed with me always
so when I when I sort of left school I
went into publishing for a few years and
then I just took the risk to like to
travel which was on Damascus in those
days back in the 60s nothing thank you
so much mister the run
thank you very much for more information
about the book TV bus visit our website
at book TV org slash book TV bus here's
a look at some upcoming book fairs and
festivals next week